now that we have a little bit of a
review of oxidation and reduction under
our belts let's see if we can apply what
we now maybe re-understand to cellular
respiration so cellular respiration for
every mole of glucose is c6 c6h12o6
we combine that maybe that's in an
aqueous state it's dissolved in water we
combine that
with six moles of
molecular oxygen and then our cells
perform cellular respiration in a whole
series of steps and i'll do more videos
on that it performs
cellular
respiration let's abbreviate it and then
we end up with
we end up with
six moles of carbon dioxide we have to
breed this oxygen in in order to perform
cellular respiration and then we have to
breathe this carbon dioxide out because
this is the byproduct of cellular
respiration six moles of carbon dioxide
six moles of water and then the whole
point the whole point of cellular
respiration is plus some energy some
energy is generated by this reaction and
our bodies store this energy well some
of it is just turns into heat but the
whole point of cellular respiration is
to store it as 38 atps which we've
learned already is the energy currency
of biological systems and then our
bodies or biological systems in general
can use these atps to contract muscles
or generate nerve impulses or grow cells
or divide cells or whatever else that a
biological system has to do in the last
video we learned a little bit about
oxidation and reduction so let's apply
those ideas here
now
we saw in the last video that a chemist
a chemist
would say let me write it this way a
chemist would say that oxidation
means losing electrons or being able to
hog them not being able to hog them
losing
electrons
while a chemist will tell you that
reduction
reduction
is gaining
electrons gaining
electrons
and if you need you know if you have
trouble remembering you know oxidation
is losing that's kind of the oil
that's the mnemonic oxidation is losing
electrons and reduction is gaining or
rig
so oil rig this is what you learn in
chemistry class now biologist or
biochemist will say oh well you know i
like to define a little bit different so
let me write this a biologist
we'll say that oxidation is losing
hydrogen atoms
hydrogen atoms
and they'll say reduction is gaining
gaining
hydrogen
hydrogen
atoms and we saw in the last video that
this definition is actually hard when
you're actually applying it to hydrogen
because it's not like a hydrogen atom
can lose itself or gain itself and the
reason why we said that these two ideas
are consistent is because if i'm talking
about a carbon and a carbon is losing a
hydrogen so you know let's say i have
some compound that looks like this maybe
it's connected to a bunch of other
things someplace else and then later on
the carbon you know let's say i have
carbon that looks like that and then i
have an oxygen that's maybe bound to
another oxygen i'm doing it very kind of
a hand wavy
explanation here and maybe that oxygen
is about bonded to something else if
this is what i start off with and then i
on the other side of this equation i end
up with something that looks like this
where the carbon is bonded to an oxygen
and maybe that other oxygen is bonded to
this hydrogen the biologist will say
the biologists say oh this carbon has
been oxidized because it lost its
hydrogen right the hydrogen went from
here i'm doing a different color went
from this carbon to this oxygen and the
biologist would also say that this
oxygen has been reduced
it's been reduced because it gained
hydrogens but the reality or maybe the
chemical the chemist definition which i
like a little bit more is over here the
carbon was because carbon is more
electronegative
right we see carbon is much more
electronegative than hydrogen and oxygen
is even more electronegative than carbon
when any of these guys bond with
hydrogen they're going to hog the
electron
so here carbon got to hog the electron
so here carbon hogs
carbon hog's
electron
while here
carbon gets its electrons hogged by
oxygen so here oxygen hogs
oxygen
hogs so by losing the hydrogen the
carbon actually lost its opportunity to
hog electrons and since it ended up
bonding with an oxygen actually not only
can't hog hydrogen's electrons but then
it gets its electrons hogged by an even
more electronegative atom so that's why
these two definitions are consistent
same thing with the oxygen here it's
bonding with another oxygen not hogging
anything but when it gains the hydrogen
when it gains the hydrogen it's able to
hog hydrogen's electrons because it's so
much more electronegative or you could
say that it's gaining electrons so
that's why these two definitions are
somewhat consistent although sometimes
they fall apart if we're not dealing
with hydrogens the chemistry definition
applies more consistently to everything
but sometimes the biologist definition
is easier to kind of glance at or you'll
actually see it written in in textbooks
so let's go back to cellular respiration
and try to figure out what's being
oxidized and reduced
so if we look over here
over here well we have our glucose and
actually i drew there i've copied and
pasted from wikipedia a glucose molecule
and actually there's one error in here
maybe i should edit it on wikipedia
there should be another hydrogen bonded
to that carbon right there but as you
see all of the hydrogens they're either
bonded to
a a oxygen or a carbon over here right
on the left hand side they're either
bonded to an oxygen or a carbon if we
were to write its oxidation state in
every case it's bonded to something
that's more electronegative so it's
going to be giving up its electron so
it'll have a
plus one oxidation state and oxygen in
every case is either bonded to a carbon
or a hydrogen and so oxygen if it's
bonded to a carbon or a hydrogen is
going to hog an electron from either one
of those guys so in every in every
situation on glucose oxygen has a two
minus or a minus two oxidation state and
carbon since this whole thing is neutral
one would think that carbon would be
would have a neutral oxidation state and
if you go through this you'll actually
find that
most of these carbons do have neutral
oxidation states let me circle a few so
for example this carbon right here it's
hogging an electron from this hydrogen
but then it gets an electron hogged by
this oxygen and then of course it does
nothing with the carbon so that's
neutral this is neutral for the same
reason this is neutral for the same
reason this one is also neutral for the
same reason it's bonded with two carbons
it has an electron hogged by oxygen but
then it hogs an electron from hydrogen
so it's neutral so four of these carbons
are neutral this carbon right here
this carbon right here has two electrons
hogged by oxygens and then it gets to
take one back from the hydrogen so it
has a plus one oxidation state and then
this one's the opposite it has two
hydrogens that it hogs from then it has
to give one away to the oxygen so this
has a minus one and so these two cancel
out so on average you can say that the
carbons in glucose have a neutral
oxidation state and i'm dealing with the
chemist definition and i'm going to show
you that they're essentially equivalent
here all of the oxygens have no
oxidation state because they're just
bonded
let me do it in a better color
no oxidation state or neutral oxidation
state because they're double bonded with
oxygen no one's hogging from anyone
they're obviously equally
electronegative if we look at the
products carbon dioxide looks like this
so in either of these cases oxygen this
oxygen is hogging two electrons from
this carbon so it has a minus two
oxidation state this oxygen is hogging
two electrons from carbon so it has a
minus two oxidation state and this
carbon is getting all of its valence
electrons all four hogged by the oxygen
so it has a plus four
oxidation state that it's lost four
electrons you can imagine because it's
getting hogged so that's carbon so we
could write this as four plus for the
carbon and then each oxygen has a two
minus and we can do the math later on to
figure out what the total is and then if
we look at the water and we've looked at
this before
the oxygen is hogging two electrons from
each from one from each hydrogen so two
minus and then each of the hydrogens
have a
plus one oxidation state
so if you want to do a half reaction
for cellular respiration and that's in
kind of the chemist sense of things just
dealing with electrons you can well you
can immediately say that look i start
with 12 hydrogens i start with 12
hydrogens on this side let me just write
it this way
so h12 on this side and they all have a
plus one oxidation state and then
cellular respiration occurs and now i
have 12 hydrogens i can write the 12 a
little bit differently here but they
still have a plus one each of them still
has a plus one oxidation state so
nothing from an oxidation reduction
point of view happens to the hydrogen
now if we do the carbon
if we do the carbon
on the left-hand side of the equation we
have six carbons they have a neutral
oxidation state but then on the
right-hand side of the equation what
happens i now have six carbons written a
little bit differently but i have six
carbons and they each have a plus four
oxidation state
which means that they have lost four
electrons or their hypothetical charge
by losing those four electrons has gone
up by four because they're losing
negatively charged atoms or actually
negatively charged electrons so the
carbon the the six carbons after
cellular respiration end up with six
oxidized carbons with plus four
oxidation states
plus so each of these got lost four
electrons we have six of them four times
six is 24
electrons these are the electrons that
the carbon lost
so we see in cellular respiration that
the carbon is oxidized
carbon oxidized
right oxidation is losing electrons we
see in cellular respiration we draw the
half reaction carbon is losing the six
carbons are losing a collective 24
electrons and then finally if i were to
do the oxygen
on this side
i've lost my equation up here
so over here i have well i have two
oxygens and i'm going to draw them a
little bit separate so i have these six
oxygens here
i have these six oxygens here that have
a minus two oxidation state
on the left hand side
so i'll draw it like this they have a
minus two oxidation state and then i
have
these 12 oxygens that are completely
neutral
and then i have
let me do that
those 12 oxygens that are completely
neutral so i won't even write an
oxidation state or oxidation number
there and then after we perform
cellular respiration what happens
well now i have
in the carbon dioxide i have 12 carbons
12 carbons that have a minus 2 oxidation
state right 6 times o2 so let me write
that down from the carbon dioxide
so i have six o2s that all have a two
minus oxidation state
and then i have another six oxygens that
have a minus two oxidation state
so plus six oxygens
that have a minus two oxidation state so
if you think about it over here i had a
collective oxidation state on all of the
oxygens these were neutral i have six
times minus two that's a minus twelve
you can kind of view it as collective
charge of all six of them six times
minus two here i have six times minus
two which is minus twelve and then i
have six times two oxygens per molecule
so that's 12 times minus two
that's minus 24. so to go from a minus
12 to a total oxidation or kind of
hypothetical charge of minus 36 i must
have gained
24
electrons and those 24 electrons that i
gained that the oxygens gained are the
same 24 electrons that the carbons lost
so that so from the chemistry point of
view it's very clear
carbon was oxidized and oxygen
oxygen
which gained electrons right it's
gaining these electrons right here rig
reduction is gaining
oxygen is
reduced and this is all a bit of review
but it's nice to see it in the context
of cellular respiration and this
actually kind of answers one of the
questions of where does this energy come
from
where does this energy come from in any
of these chemical reactions when you see
energy being produced it's because
electrons are going from a higher energy
state to a lower energy state right if i
have an electron that's up here at a
high energy state high
and it is able to go to a more
comfortable state a lower orbital a
lower energy orbital so low energy or
more stable energy state it'll generate
energy in the form of heat or maybe this
can do some work in some way help make
atp molecules and so when you see these
half reactions you see these 24
electrons that are
being lost by carbon carbon is being
oxidized and they're going to oxygen
they're going in a whole series of steps
it's not just happening in kind of one
huge explosion it's happening over a
huge series of steps
and as it does that it's entering lower
and lower energy states and as these
electrons entered the lower energy
states essentially by going from the
carbons and being pushed to the oxygens
that's where the energy is coming from
that's where the energy to make the 38
atps is coming from so so far we you
know we talked a little bit about how a
chemist views oxidation i touched in the
beginning of the video of how a
biologist views oxidation and then we
saw that cellular respiration from a
chemist point of view is clearly showing
that the carbon is being oxidized
it's losing electrons
and that the oxygen is being reduced
it's gaining electrons it's being
reduced that the electrons are going
from this carbon and they're going
essentially to these oxygens right here
now how does the biology definition of
oxidation hold up well here it holds up
pretty well because you can imagine
over here all of the hydrogens in the
equation are associated with glucose
right and so they're either bonded if
you look at the if you actually look at
the structure of glucose the hydrogens
are either bonded to carbons or oxygens
right so these are bonded to carbons and
oxygens but when you go on the right
hand side of the equation all of the
hydrogens
all of the hydrogens are only
bonding with oxygen so net net carbon
definitely lost hydrogens
and hydrogens and oxygen definitely
gained hydrogens let me write that down
we see in respiration carbon lost
hydrogens
carbon
lost hydrogens
and oxygen gained hydrogens
oxygen
gained
hydrogens
and that's consistent because we see
that by losing hydrogens we are being
oxidized from a biologist's point of
view and by gaining hydrogens oxygen is
being reduced and just so you can kind
of make sense of this when you see this
in you know when i start drawing out the
mechanisms which i will hopefully not
make too hairy this process of
transferring these hydrogens is
facilitated by molecules like nad plus
and fad and we'll see that but it's
really the if we just want to reconcile
the two notions as the hydrogens are
being transferred from one
electronegative atom to another
electronegative atom what's really being
transferred is the opportunity to hog
electrons if carbon has a hydrogen it
gets to hog the electrons but then if
that hydrogen goes from the carbon and
the whole atom not just the nucleus the
whole atom goes to the oxygen now the
oxygen has gained that electron that it
can hog and carbon has lost the electron
so carbon has been oxidized and oxygen
has been reduced and i've mentioned this
in previous videos but probably the most
confusing thing about oxidation
is that you always want to say hi that
must have something to do with oxygen
and it does the word really comes from
what would occident do to something so
oxygen when it bonds with things it
loses it takes away their electrons or
in a reaction it'll often take away the
hydrogens and take away the hydrogens
from the carbon in this situation so
that's where the term oxidation comes
from but you don't have to have oxygen
anywhere in your reaction for oxidation
or reduction to occur anyway hopefully
you found that reasonably useful this
was actually a huge pain point for me
when you know i learned i got
comfortable with the chemistry
definition of oxidation reduction and
then all of a sudden you open up your
biology book and they start talking
about losing and gaining hydrogens as
opposed to electrons and it took me a
while to really reconcile these two
notions